software it's not like engineering
something easy like a bridge where you
start with a blueprint
build it to spec then forget about it
software is dynamic with a lot of moving
parts and requirements that evolve over
time
developers build apps on top of a
mountain of abstractions and nobody
fully understands how every layer works
that's okay because we just need to make
sure that our code matches the
requirements of the product test driven
development is scientifically proven to
reduce defects and improve the
maintainability of a code base but it
does require some additional effort
one option is manual testing where a
human being clicks on every button and
fills out every form then assigns a
bunch of jira tickets so they can be
backlogged by the developers
but that's not very efficient for a
large scale product a better approach is
to use automated testing tools that
allow developers to write code for the
sole purpose of testing the main
application code in a code base you'll
often find files that end in
test or dot spec inside you'll first
find a line of code that describes the
feature or thing that's being tested
that's known as a test suite and it
contains one or more individual tests
an individual test usually starts with
it followed by a description
of what is being tested the idea is to
describe the behavior of the code in
human readable terms
inside the test the code will be
executed then one or more
expectations or assertions are used to
check that the code produces the
expected result if the expectation
returns false then the test fails
if it's true it passes test runners like
jest or karma
can run all your tests automatically in
the background or on a continuous
integration server before you deploy
now there are many different automated
testing strategies that you should be
aware of
at the most granular level we have unit
testing which is designed to test
individual functions or methods
like does this function return the
proper value when given the arguments of
a
and b then we have integration testing
to determine how well different
components or modules work together like
is the component
able to use the database service to get
data from the server at the highest
level we have end-to-end testing which
usually happens in a mock browser or
device
and simulates actual user behaviors like
clicking on buttons and filling out
forms
it's like having a robot to do all your
manual testing for you
and that's not all there are many other
types like performance and smoke testing
which i'll explain
in my upcoming test driven development
breakdown hit the like button if you
want to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one